oh the [ __ ] list is gonna be fun today
it is gonna be fun to round up the the
[ __ ] list
oh my god i ca you can't even make this
[ __ ] up you can't make this up
you can't i call it the [ __ ] list and
here this [ __ ] is flushing [ __ ]
down the toilet
flushing
classified
documents from the national archives
down the [ __ ] toilet
i've said before everything trump
touches turns to liquid [ __ ]
rick wilson says everything trump
touches dies but everything trump
touches turns to liquid
[ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] are we here
in this timeline the way that we are
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
that we have to sit here talking about
this [ __ ]
that a president united states would rip
up a [ __ ] document
eat it he's putting it in his [ __ ]
mouth apparently omarosa
you remember omarosa she's the one from
the apprentice the one that worked in
the white house as a staff
i believe in the communications
department i don't remember she wasn't
even there that long there was a big
ordeal about how she left and how she
got fired
but omarosa was saying how it was weird
that he was eating documents and
everyone's like oh she's [ __ ] crazy
nope
apparently not
we are in the [ __ ] timeline
in our country someone at home office
unplugged the [ __ ] national timeline
and plug that [ __ ] back in plug
it back in reset that son of a [ __ ]
this is ridiculous it really is [ __ ]
stupid
that we have to we have to do serious
[ __ ] political commentary
and pretend like it is [ __ ] normal
that a president united states would
stand in a room with staffers looking at
a piece of paper that he knew would get
him in trouble or he thought he thought
he well i don't want anyone to see this
so he rips it up in pieces and sticks it
in his [ __ ] mouth and starts eating
it
have you ever have you ever [ __ ]
looked at a document in your hand and
thought you know the best course of
action here is to rip this [ __ ] thing
up and eat it
the only other time that i've ever
[ __ ] heard or seen of someone
flushing down the toilet is in a
gangster movie when they're flushing
drugs and evidence are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me then this [ __ ] guy is on
video in front of a microphone in a
podium at his rallies talking about how
toilets don't flush good enough i can't
flush a whole file full of documents
down a [ __ ] toilet i need the heavy
flush when you're when you're flushing
boxes of documents [ __ ]
and then this dumb [ __ ] releases
a statement talking about how oh it's
normal it's normal for the national
archives to come retrieve
presidential records
and then the national archive apparently
gives a referral to the department of
justice about the handling of those
documents look if it was just normal
[ __ ] handling fine whatever yeah sure
but when he releases a statement saying
it's fake news and it's all [ __ ] you
know that [ __ ] is a hundred
percent true
that's where we're at anything that
[ __ ] said is fake news and ain't
true is the 100 [ __ ] truth that's
where we gotta start
like we have to start there
and there's still dumb [ __ ] out
there that think it's a good idea to
have this son of a [ __ ] in charge of
anything absolutely anything
absolutely [ __ ]
craziness
that we had a president united states
who was [ __ ] tearing up documents and
eating them and flushing them down the
[ __ ] toilet
and we think and we think in our history
that the smoking gun the tape the [ __ ]
that that nixon was deleting off the
tapes the recordings that he had well
that was oh my god i was egregious
jesus christ nixon looks like a shiny
[ __ ] rose at this point
those people who push nixon out of
office should be [ __ ] ashamed of
themselves
that's where the [ __ ] we're at
and there are still [ __ ] out
there in the country that are running
around you work with them you talk to
them you see them in the grocery store
that thinks it's a good idea
for this dumb [ __ ] to be in
charge of anything
anything
and of course you know the onslaught of
of the right wing is gonna say oh
liberals are so upset that someone who
doesn't rip up documents who doesn't
[ __ ] flush documents down the toilet
this is ridiculous how could you say
such egregious things about our orange
mussolini jesus it's all fake news
anyways but who doesn't flush documents
down the toilet because here's the thing
here's what they have to do they have to
say it's [ __ ] and they have to
defend it all at the same time because
they know it's [ __ ] real and the
reason why we know it's real because
he's saying it's not
like he's confirming it to us
this story comes out that he's flushing
documents and eating [ __ ] paper
and he's like nope that didn't happen
that's fake news confirmed
[ __ ] confirmed fact checked right
there he [ __ ] said he didn't do it so
there it is
he realizes that right they [ __ ] know
that right
they know that that's where you have to
have the starting point
in the narrative with this dumb
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] criminal
and you know he wasn't eating and
[ __ ] flushing documents that was you
know his [ __ ] mcdonald's order that
he was giving to someone
they already know his mcdonald's order
why would you write that down they know
what he gets from mcdonald's that fat
[ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
and especially in the situation where we
have to try to make this [ __ ] funny
you dickweed you [ __ ] come on
give us some [ __ ] leeway here
we can't even make that we can't even
make this [ __ ] up anymore you can't make
this [ __ ] up imagine standing imagine
being an interpreter
and you just listened to this
[ __ ] say to putin and putin just
holds told him to be his little [ __ ]
and donald trump said i'm your little
[ __ ]
in a private room with you and one other
interpreter
and you're taking [ __ ] notes and
donald trump the president of the united
states turns to you and says hey give me
those notes
because he knows if they step outside
that room that [ __ ] those [ __ ] notes
are part of the presidential archives
he rips them up in little pieces i'm
just snowballing here
i wasn't there
but just imagine this
this is where we're at this is the [ __ ]
that we have to consider
rips up the [ __ ] notes
stuffs them in his mouth in front of
putin
and eats the documents so he can [ __ ]
them out later
while he's tweeting
and republicans are running around
thinking [ __ ]
biting somehow beholding the putin get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you stupid [ __ ] traitors
you people are [ __ ] traitors if you
still support this [ __ ] if
you're still in bed with this son of a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] traitor
you are unamerican just like mike pence
said you were [ __ ] unamerican and it
was a violent insurrection it was an
attempt to overthrow the constitution of
the united states and he's hiding it
he's eaten documents to hide the [ __ ]
not just january 6 but russia too
guarantee it [ __ ] guarantee it
and when the when when they write a
story about it when they find it [ __ ]
somewhere he'll [ __ ] release a
statement saying it's [ __ ] fake news
and we'll know it's [ __ ] real
that's what always pissed me off when he
would accidentally tell the truth when
he was the president united states when
he was the president for four [ __ ]
years and that [ __ ] would
accidentally stumble into the truth it
would piss me off because i was like oh
[ __ ] it's not that he was right it's not
that he was telling the truth i was like
god damn it i got tricked like my mind
my mind he'd accidentally tell the truth
you know what i'm talking about you'd he
would accidentally tell the truth right
and your mind's like well that can't be
[ __ ] true he's saying it
but here we are in this timeline
where we have to deal with the reality
of the person who these [ __ ] idiots
put in charge
and still want in charge mind you they
want him to be the speaker of the house
speaker of the house he's gonna be our
king get the [ __ ] out of here
we have to live with the reality that
this dumb [ __ ] was tearing up
notes tearing up documents and eating
them
to destroy them
think about how [ __ ] desperate you
have to be for someone not to see that
[ __ ]
and then and then to [ __ ] about how
toilets don't flush good enough
they j they just don't flush a whole
file folder full of documents it's
ridiculous
i mean i flush and i flush and i flush
and i flush and the folder doesn't go
down
you know the staples the papers are
stapled together the paper clips kind of
hold the documents and i'm flushing and
i'm flushing and i'm flushing and i'm
flushing
you thought he was talking about his
[ __ ] his mcdonald's [ __ ] turds
nope he was talking about documents the
whole [ __ ] time
and god knows god knows what the [ __ ]
he's talking about when he's talking
about shower heads at this point
who the [ __ ] even can tell what he's
talking about when he's talking about
the shower heads
who [ __ ] knows
it's got to be something [ __ ] weird
something [ __ ] crazy off the wall
doubt me just wait
just [ __ ] wait you ain't gonna be
able to make this [ __ ] up
you won't be able to make this [ __ ] up
it just it's [ __ ] ridiculous
that we're standing around having these
conversations about how the former
president united states was flushing
documents down the toilet to [ __ ]
destroy them
i mean last week it was burn bags like
that makes sense like burnham yeah sure
but you're so [ __ ] desperate you're
gonna go to the mob movie type [ __ ] and
flushed our flushing [ __ ] down the
toilet
when the feds show up
come on you've seen good fellas you've
seen it you've seen it when the feds
show up to the house
she takes the drugs and she flushes it
down the toilet
where do you think he gets this [ __ ]
he doesn't think of this himself
he's watched it somewhere
he's watched it somewhere on tv on the
boob tube
you know
where all his information and research
comes from
this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ] guy i
cannot believe that we have people in
this country that think it is a good
idea for this guy to even [ __ ] be in
charge of putting on his [ __ ] pants
in the morning
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with you
people
you people really need to get your
[ __ ] heads checked quick like fast in
a hurry we need mental health care in
this country fast quick and in a [ __ ]
hurry
you know i've been railing against
fascism for [ __ ] months now months
months a year over a year two [ __ ]
years i've been railing about fascism
and how it's at our front [ __ ]
doorstep but maybe the mental health
care is a way [ __ ] bigger need in
this country
that people can't put two and two
together with this dumb [ __ ]
and it seems as if big news is going to
drop this week
i can't figure out if this is the big
news or it's something bigger
that the national archives has sent a
referral to the department of justice to
see how trump was handling [ __ ]
documents
whether he was destroying them or not
what the [ __ ]
because mitch mcconnell came out and
said in front of a microphone said
exactly what mike pence said to to
not in so many words but basically
trump's a [ __ ] loser he's un-american
and those people january 6 are [ __ ]
criminals and anyone who conspired with
them
needs to go to prison
for all intents and purposes
that's what mitch mcconnell said in
front of a microphone and that
[ __ ] doesn't give anything
that's not measured
he knows he knows something that's why
he's waited until now to say it
he's waited until now to say
it and we have a lot of news that's
being suppressed
because of this [ __ ] toilet story
because of this national archives going
down and getting 15 boxes and him saying
oh it was just normal [ __ ]
i stole them in a normal capacity
they were supposed to go to the
presidential library which he's not
going to have a presidential library
it's it'll be a coloring book factory at
at best
at best it'll be a coloring book factory
jesus christ for at this point we're
going to have burn bags uh toilets
septic tanks
and turds as [ __ ] as documents at the
presidential coloring book factory
jesus [ __ ] christ
this is real life this is [ __ ] real
life this isn't [ __ ] fake
and everyone's going ah jibadin gas
prices
and the media can't pluck their head out
of their [ __ ] asses to realize that
joe biden
is back it's a back to normal type thing
it's back to normal type thing dumb
[ __ ] pluck your head out of your ass
and report [ __ ] the way that it needs to
be reported
this guy's not [ __ ] eating documents
and flushing them down the [ __ ]
toilet
nor is he nor is he
getting on his knees with putin
you [ __ ] idiots
pluck it out it's enough of this [ __ ]
i think gabe's gonna be joining us here
in the second half of the first hour
but i think what we should do is go
ahead
enough of the ranting
enough of the rant
get on with the shitless tony get on
with it
because we've got a lot of things uh to
get to that's trending we have uh that
of course this flush gate and we have
the trucker convoy thing still going on
uh these [ __ ] fascists still talking
about this this [ __ ] made up [ __ ]
[ __ ] up there in canada you know they're
causing chaos uh trying to make it seem
like there's an actual [ __ ] crisis
going on you know manufacture crisis is
what the right wing does now we have
this problem over in russia
we we also have the maggie haberman
story
it's circulating around al franken's is
is trying to decide if he's going to
rerun
and we also have inflation news which
again
i i don't know why we have to keep going
over this and why the media keeps
getting this all [ __ ] around they they
getting this all [ __ ] around
but let's do it let's start the count
line let's get into the [ __ ] list let's
go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends start that countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast this is a shitless roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends of the day
um caitlin's already trying to get my
attention about the christina bob story
i think this is that's that's one of the
stories i was saying it was suppressed i
think we're going to talk about this
story i think it's very [ __ ]
significant
i think that's very big news some of the
subpoenas that have happened in the last
few days um some of the things that are
happening in the january 6 select
committee and also what the doj is going
to do about it what they're not going to
do about it of course a lot of people
are bitching moaning and complaining
that the doj isn't saying anything
rob reiner i like you rob i like you rob
but you're way off the mark man you're
way off the mark department of justice
is not going to come out in front of a
microphone and announce anything they're
not going to why haven't why the [ __ ]
are we still doing this where we think
the department of justice is gonna come
out and [ __ ] say yep we're gonna
arrest that guy and that guy and that
guy just wait another month
no that's not what's happening god damn
it
stop with the [ __ ] they've they've
[ __ ] charged almost 800 [ __ ]
800 800 [ __ ] 11 of them with
seditious conspiracy and that
investigation is ongoing and when you do
a conspiracy investigation you continue
to collect evidence and you continue to
get those people that are wrapped up in
the conspiracy to tell you more about
the conspiracy by pressure pressuring
them with charges and superseding
indictments that's what's going to
happen
mark my words in the next six months
stewart rhodes and all those oath
keepers will be added to a superseding
indictment which will indict more people
on their indictment on that superseding
indictment that is what's going to
happen
and i it's it's very unclear at this
point we know that he talked to the
january 6th select committee for six
hours and it was stuff concerning before
january 5th that's significant
everyone's like oh well why didn't he
say anything about the fifth or the
sixth because it might just might
endanger the investigation that the
department of justice is doing
so that's why the january 6 select
committee would probably forego that
testimony on the fifth and the sixth
because the fifth and the sixth is
probably when the most crimes happen for
the conspiracy
where they were acting
and who they were acting with
so calm the [ __ ] down calm the [ __ ] down
with the department of justice [ __ ]
they're getting there trust me
you can see it you can see it and who
they're charging and when they're
charging them
and also the january 6 select committee
is collecting mountains of [ __ ]
evidence
mountains of [ __ ] i mean they're
having to tape it together
and [ __ ] sift through a bunch of
septic tanks to find it but you know
they're getting there
[ __ ] me
it's ridiculous
but everyone needs to just settle down
because here's the thing politically you
want to know about the 2022 midterms how
[ __ ] sweet would it be how [ __ ]
sweet would it be for these [ __ ] gq
peers to pick a bunch of trump pumping
fools to be their candidates in the
general election for or in the midterm
huh how [ __ ] sweet would it be for
them to tie themselves to donald trump
100
all [ __ ] year
and then all the [ __ ] hammer drops in
the fall huh how [ __ ] sweet would
that be you want politics there's
politics i'm always talking about how
politics and government are separate
well let's do that thing
a [ __ ] i would i would love for
democrats to run all around the country
about a bunch of people who were
propping up criminals
look what they did look they tried to
overturn the constitution in the united
states they're [ __ ] traitors
seditious conspiracy members of congress
oh well
it might be easy to beat a [ __ ]
candidate for congress who is charged
with seditious conspiracy to overturn
the constitution of the united states
come on
think about it
the republicans are the ones who wanted
this [ __ ] to be political in the first
place
[ __ ] democrats wanted the 911 style
commission for for weeks
for weeks they wanted the 911 style
commission they passed it in the house
republicans didn't want it in the senate
because they wanted the political fight
that's what they wanted that's what they
wanted because they thought they would
win that fight because they think
democrats liberals moderates people in
the democratic party tent are a bunch of
[ __ ] that's what they think and i
think they're wrong dead [ __ ] wrong
they think
they think merrick garland is a squish
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
merrick garland ain't making the
decisions on the prosecutions in the
first place almost 800 indictments 800
people indicted in the dec by the dc
united states attorney
right
got it the the u.s attorney in the dc
district has charged almost 800 people
including 11 people with seditious
conspiracy
which is ongoing and will probably have
superseding indictments you're gonna
hear that word a lot
superseding indictments
conspiracy you're gonna hear those words
over and over and over again in the next
six months
and it's gonna take a little bit but you
know maybe we want it to take a little
bit
maybe it would be nice to take a little
bit
i don't know i'm just saying politically
i would if i was running for congress
and my opponent was was out on bail
for uh or or locked up in a dc jail for
sus seditious conspiracy
because they helped [ __ ] uh
deal a pardon for their [ __ ]
for their actions to overturn the
government of the united states and
commit a cheeto dust kangaroo coup and
you're tied up in that conspiracy yeah
that's who i want to run against
i'm just saying if i had a choice
that's who i'd want to run against
and that might happen in a few of these
districts
kaelin kaelin's not going to give up on
this christina bob i'm going to get to
the christina bob thing
send me the link she's probably not